we love any moment on this show when we
can highlight incredible people making a
difference in the world and our next
guest certainly falls under that
category brooke johns is an er nurse who
goes above and beyond and even when
she's not on the clock you will find her
at work spreading joy to her patience
one braid at a time please welcome
brooke john
[Applause]
thank you for having me
okay brooke you're an er nurse yes and
that is not enough you want to go an
extra mile beyond that yes um in the er
we we see people at their
at worst um they are in pain they're
scared they're grieving
and
i in my job get to help
comfort them
how do you know
what to say when to say it is it an art
form can anybody learn it do you have it
inherently i think that you can learn it
but i also think that it comes from
being able to sit in the dark with
people you can't fix it you can't say
anything that's going to make some
things better
but you can hold a space for people
how did you discover
that
braids would come into the picture how
did that actually literally come about
the first situation situation was
actually my friend
she was hospitalized at the hospital
they work at that southern hills
hospital and she i got special
permission
uh to go up and visit her during these
coveted times
simply because i worked there
and because she was hospitalized for so
long i mean if you think about it when
when you're sick at home
your
self-care comes second you know you're
in your pajamas all day did you brush
your hair i don't know you know and
multiply that by 10 times and that's how
these people are feeling in the hospital
they're not well enough to be at home
so
upon going up to visit her i recognized
that she
hadn't had she didn't have the strength
to be able to brush her own hair
so i asked her if she wouldn't mind if i
brushed it out for her and and braided
it so it wouldn't get tangled again
so
yeah
okay
this is it's just so beautiful
it's so moving yeah
goodness
how did this set you off on a path
uh
i noticed it it's not just about the
braid you know um yes her hair was now
brushed and
braided and she felt better simply
because she was
she was well kept and she looked better
but it's the conversation that we had
the time spent
that human connection that we all crave
that she was a different person when i
left and
it just got my wheels spinning that
there were perhaps
lots of these ladies sitting in the
hospital
wanting to connect with somebody needing
to connect with somebody and the braid
is just a bonus you know there is
something i feel very intimate between
women
when you braid somebody's hair it's
something your mom does for you or a
loved neighbor you know it's
it is
just a very
safe and comforting gesture
and i have gotten to
be exposed to some of the bravest people
that have
literally stories that will bring you to
your niece
and i get to listen to them
i heard that you've also inspired others
because your bravery was obviously
bringing something really positive
that felt good that was tangible that
was evident and you inspired others to
join you yeah i have had a few of the
nurses go up and and braid with me and
they all say the same thing i mean it's
just what a great experience i feel like
i got more than i gave
and
it's true when you
when you listen to and watch and help
people you always get more out of it
than you give i think what you're doing
is anything but little it's so huge and
is it true that you and your fellow
nurses are like doing all of this out of
your own pocket
yes
so i i do purchase the brushes and the
hair um little hair ties that i use and
the
the biggest fan favorite is the spray-in
conditioner you know the detangler
but yes i i don't view it as oh this is
coming out of my pocket those are my
tools those are my tools to be able to
help people so
well uh we would love to help you
continue to do the amazing work here and
sally beauty is going to give you a five
thousand dollar gift card
[Applause]
and i
i really think that
sometimes i need to meet people like you
i need to hear your stories when we all
leave here we're probably going to go
watch the news we're going to see a lot
of stuff out there that's happening that
just feels bigger than our control
and
maybe little things are the thing we
need
because they're not little they're big
and i just love what you do because
you're going to make me know that life
is good with good people and that there
are people taking care of each other out
there and it is not all broken and you
are my personal hope so thank you so
much for doing what you do
we need to know
um about the brooks out there in the
world and thank you for just being who
you are and taking care of others thank
you thank you so much
[Music]